congratulations to the Texans they won
they got off the schneid after losing 41
to 7 to the Baltimore Ravens and I
thought the Colts would go in and win
the game so I'm a little salty cuz I
want to be right nothing against the
Texans I just thought the Colts would
win so I'd like to be correct and I'd
like to be accurate and like Colts fans
I'm a little bit upset that there was a
moment late in the game that didn't get
the attention that it should have now
look I get I don't want to take away
from the Texans victory but what's
everybody gonna be talking about this
morning that's what I need to talk about
and what they're gonna be talking about
is what happened in the final three
minutes of the game for starters the
Colts decide to go for it on fourth and
seven from the Texans 47 you could go
either way with that you could punt it
or you could go for fourth and seven
it's a little long if you're watching on
TV eg Cobra Chris ed had plenty of time
great job by the wall to give him time
he made the decision to run a little bit
too late he got tackled a yards short
now I don't like the fact that the Colts
called a timeout before that play go
ahead and take the delay in punt it then
let that be the thing that makes your
decision because I want those three
timeouts if I'm giving them the ball
back they gave him the ball back with
two timeouts didn't get the first down
fourth and seven a little bit long and
I'll tell you what great job getting a
hand on the ball it kept you Kobe perset
from stretching the ball out and maybe
getting it to the sticks so that gives
the Texans the ball back game over right
wrong there's still time left
beyond the timeouts beyond the
two-minute warning you're gonna have to
move the ball you're gonna have to do
something you can't just start taking
knees so Texans moving the ball and
there was a key play with 148 left
deshaun Watson runs the ball and as
Watson is being tackled the ball gets
punched out by Darius Leonard of the
cult's and here's the problem that's
watch this play on NBCSN I'll explain it
on the radio as Watson is falling there
and when you see it live you don't know
what happened and then all of a sudden
is five Colts pointing the other way and
there's an official shaking his head no
no no no no that guy didn't see the
fumble come out I'm telling you watch
that playback that guy didn't see the
ball coming out the ball was coming out
and from the angles that we saw there
were only two other angles it sure looks
like Darius Leonard
has his hands on the ball in fact he
pulls a hand out to make sure everyone
knows I got the ball here's another
angle you can't see yeah there's the
ball the balls out and just the way he's
rolling it looks like a guy who's got
possession of the ball so what are we
doing that instance with fewer than two
minutes can't throw the red flag all
replays are initiated by the replay
assistant and/or the league office and
there wasn't a replay review that was
initiated and the Texans foolishly took
a timeout before the next play now the
Colts had taken a timeout the Texans
didn't take it to kill the clock but the
Texans took a timeout giving the
powers-that-be
more time to look at whether or not they
should have a full blown replay review
there should have been in that moment a
full blown review there should have been
there clearly should have been and the
NFL has a Twitter account for its
officiating Department and there was
eventually a tweet posted saying there
was no clear visual evidence of a
recovery by the defense well that's not
the question
the question is should there have been a
replay review and the standard there
isn't whether or not there's clear
visual evidence of a recovery by the
defense the question when you're
initiating an automatic review is there
clear visual evidence that the ruling on
the field was accurate and clearly there
wasn't this justified a closer look this
required taking the time to explore
whether or not there is a camera angle
out there that would show Darius Leonard
with the ball in his possession look the
first part of it's easy the balls out
the second part of it is more difficult
who had possession now it very well may
have been that the officials decided
there was simultaneous possession and by
rule when there's simultaneous
possession the ball goes to the team
that had last been in possession of it
but if Leonard had possession of it and
Watson managed to fight through and get
simultaneous possession by rule then it
would have been the Colts ball we don't
know unless we look now maybe the end
result would have been
inconclusive there is no clear and
obvious visual evidence the ruling on
the field was incorrect if that's the
case fine but sometimes you just have to
do it you've got to check the box you've
got to let the people know that the end
result can be relied upon people
wouldn't have liked it people may have
disagreed people may have interpreted
the visual evidence differently but
remember it's got to be the 50 drunks in
a bar all saying that's a bad call and
we don't know unless we look and and
keep this in mind there are plenty of
camera angles but the people in the
truck the Fox production truck need to
have time to scan through them all and
all we saw were two angles if you do a
full blown replay review maybe they find
some obscure camera that happened to be
pointed in direction where you actually
and this has happened before
where with the benefit of time you do
find an angle that makes it conclusive
and maybe there would have been an angle
that they would have tripped over if
they'd had the time that is inherent to
a full blown replay review so a lot of
reasons to go ahead and do this and I
can't think of one reason not to do it
because again the standard isn't whether
or not a river on and/or the replay
assistant decide in that moment before
the next play that there is no clear
visual evidence of a recovery by the
defense the question is is there clear
visual evidence that there wasn't a
recovery by the defense is there clear
visual evidence that they got it right
on the field and I talked about this on
radio and I don't want to be too hard on
the official that we see at the top of
the screen but the way I assess his body
language if we can play that again just
watch the official at the top of the
screen who's at the line of scrimmage
when the ball is snapped from the take
it from the top the official at the top
of the screen when the ball is snapped
moves down alongside and there's just
kind of a nonchalance the official
doesn't really watch him he it's just
like yeah okay ran the ball okay walking
out walking out okay there's the ball
and
it's like he didn't even see the ball
come out shaking his head no no no no
yes yes yes yes yes the ball came out
yes mister official the ball came out I
just don't know that if he was paying
attention right and and look at you
you're out there for three hours the
games almost over sometimes you miss
things that's why we have replay review
that's why we need sky judge bottom line
is with the benefit of time from a full
blown replay review there may have been
an angle that would have allowed our
River on to conclude that the Colts had
the ball and obviously an important
moment in the game if the Colts have the
ball back with 142 to play down three
potentially changes the outcome of the
game an important moment and just from
the standpoint of and you gotta think
about this right you got to sell these
rulings to the people and it's hard to
sell or replay review ruling to the
people if you don't do the review just
do it quickly but do it do it and also
remember remember the replay review
process is only as good as the angles
that are served up by the network maybe
someone would have found an angle that
would have better reflected what
transpired there because when I see
Darius Leonard moving the way he is and
stick in that hand I he's got the ball
in the other hand he's not letting his
hand off that ball unless he's damned
sure he's got that ball there's other
guys who can who can do this it's our
ball he doesn't need to do that the mere
fact that he's doing that tells me he's
got the ball with his other hand now I
know we need to have the visual evidence
to see it but again take the time look
for the evidence and if you don't find
it you don't find it but at least at
least it keeps me and others from saying
why the hell didn't you do the replay
review they should have there was no
reason not to here's Frank Reich head
coach of the Indianapolis Colts on the
fumble after last night's game I didn't
see the review then he showed it on the
scoreboard you know they didn't show it
on the scoreboard not sure why but you
know they showed it in our coaches box
the officials and I was trying to get
him to review up with the officials on
the sideline told me it was being
reviewed and then the text was called
timeout so it gave him it was inside of
two minutes
so that gave them in New York even more
time to review it so obviously they
obviously they saw it and didn't think
it was a fumble but it still wasn't a
full-blown replay review they should
have taken the time to do that and Frank
I know why they didn't show it on the
scoreboard at the stadium because you
weren't playing in Indianapolis you were
paying hit in Houston come on man
anytime they don't show it on the screen
that means they don't want people seeing
what happened and what happened was the
ball was out and quite possibly Darius
Leonard recovered it and look the Colts
still could have won the game that's
just the the obvious thing we can point
to as proof of why some folks may have a
little angst this morning but T Y Hilton
and Hilton admitted it himself after the
game it's on him he dropped a couple of
passes on third down last night key
third downs in the second half that
would have extended drives and given the
Colts opportunity to score more than 17
points and one of them was bizarre and I
have to go back and watch this I got to
make sure I'm not losing my mind here
they were given Jonathan Joseph credit
for breaking up a long pass that T Y
Hilton dropped and I didn't see Jonathan
Joseph's hand in there knocking it out I
saw T Y Hilton with two hands on the
ball and not reeling it in so the Colts
lose the Texans win the Titans are
Larkin folks the Titans are Larkin if
they run the table they win the division
but for now the Houston Texans take over
first place in the AFC South at seven
and four and the Colts fall to six in
five
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports